hey everyone so it has been a year since
Apple has announced their emergency SOS
satellite services for the iPhone 14
which now are carrying into the iPhone
15 now thankfully in the past year that
the emergency satellite services have
been operating I thankfully have not had
to use them but what is most exciting
about this is the fact that it is there
if you are in a car accident if you're
off the grid and need service or help or
you're injured you'll easily be able to
connect to satellites and get the help
that you need so now that it's been over
a year they have some new additional
announcements to make I'm so excited I
got a chance to chat with cayenne from
Apple again if you guys remember I did
an interview last year chatting with
some of the executives from Apple about
all of the things emergency satellite
services but now this year we're back
with some updates and some new news they
now have a partnership with AAA and if
you're not familiar with them well you
will be shortly I am so excited it's so
good to see you again so this is the
year anniversary of the launch from the
iPhone 15 so how's it all been going and
what news do you have for us today sure
well it's been going great you know I
would say that iPhone of course has a
wide range of safety features and this
is just one of them and it combines the
ability of having great Innovation
across Hardware software and
infrastructure and of course that stuff
is so important when there's an
emergency and like you said one year ago
we launch emergency SOS via satellite
and on the iPhone 14 and 15 models it
uses custom hardware and software
components it was the first in a
smartphone to allow users to connect to
a satellite and message with emergency
service providers to get the help they
need when they're outside of Wi-Fi or
sell your service and it's just been
remarkable I mean just in the one year
it's had an extraordinary impact helping
people all around the world in each of
the 16 regions where it's launched for
things like fire medical emergencies uh
search and rescue natural disasters um
it's just been incredible to see um that
it's been able to help people get
connected and get help where they need
it now I think it's also really exciting
I got a chance to chat with Margaret
from from tripa a well Tria a is
delighted to be collaborating with apple
every second of every minute of every
hour of every day of every week you get
it we are handling a road service call
32 million times a year and so now
Apple's technology puts you know that
ability right in the palm of their hand
so we agreed with apple that listen this
service is too important with someone
off the grid you guys now have this AAA
partnership so how's that going how that
all come about and how is this going to
help customers who now have this access
to a whole new network for sure you know
we saw so much impact helping in these
emergency situations so it turns out a
lot of emergency situations when you're
off the grid actually have to do with
help with your vehicle and so this was a
great opportunity to expand the
capability and help even more people and
we partnered with AAA uh they're North
America's largest and most trusted
membership provider service um they
service like 30 million call calls
across North America for vehicle help
they're able to service a wide range of
issues with vehicles vehicle types like
gasoline or electric vehicles and they
have this compelling really great
Nationwide Network and they've been
working to also Shore up the support in
remote areas uh where there is no sales
service so they can continue helping
users and they've been a great partner
to work with uh it's also great because
this is part of their vision for being
able to help anyone wherever they are if
they need help uh and it's been great to
work with them through our uh roadside
assistance capability all through
satellite at the same time now obviously
I've seen this I've visited you guys
done the demos but for anyone who has
never seen this in action can you kind
of walk us through like what's this
whole process like to actually get help
if you are off the grid for sure so
what's great is that when you're an
emergency the first thing that you
should do is call 911 and we will try to
get you connected through your carer
another carer in the area but if that
doesn't work because you're off the grid
um you will see an prompt on your phone
that's right there that says emergency
text via satellite and you just tap on
that and you're taken through a set of
very simple questions to characterize
your emergency and that's based on real
questions that emergency providers will
want to know and that we will send your
answers um up through a satellite and
we'll guide you very simply pointing to
the sky with a very simple UI interface
um to teach you how to stay connected
and we will send over your answers uh
your medical ID if you have one set up
your location which includes your
elevation even your battery life on your
iPhone so that all goes up there and if
you have an emergency contact set up
through your medical ID they will even
get to see a transcript as you go along
with that conversation with emergency
service providers so it's super powerful
and we've seen just some incredible
results I mean just a few examples in
the past year we had a man get rescued
by helicopter after his car plummeted
400 ft off a cliff in Mount Wilson and
you know he ended ended up being rescued
as part of a car accident uh so we had
crash detection working hand inand with
the emergency SOS feature to get him
connected to help to to get him rescued
it's just been so amazing to see that
the capability has been able to help
people in their time of need um and get
them connected to these um life-saving
uh rescue teams I mean that's really
incredible and I think you know we've
all been in that scenario where we
haven't had cell reception and
thankfully now you know on the iPhone 14
and the iPhone 15 this all has that
satellite cap cap abilities and now with
iOS 17 you guys have the new check-in
feature so I love that you're kind of
updating the ios's with you know all
these different features that can take
advantage of that so how does the
check-in feature kind of work with
satellite as well yeah the check-in
feature as you said is available on iOS
17 and allows you to through messages
app let people know like friends and
family um that you have arrived safely
at a location and there's a few settings
that you can set up um just so that they
know that you've arrived safely or if
you're delayed and you haven't answered
your check-in on on your phone they'll
also be notified so it's a great another
way to build on to these great safety
features you we talked about Crash
detection we talked about medical ID the
other thing people are also using the
emergency uh satellite service for is f
find my location update so even if it's
not an emergency they're able to use
that when they're off the grid to let
friends and family know where they are
and that they're doing safe and in fact
one of the great announcements that we
have today is that the emergency SOS via
satellite feature last year when we
announced it on iPhone 14 we said the
service was available for free for 2
years um for iPhone 14 users well we're
thrilled to announce today that uh for
these existing iPhone 14 users we are
extending that uh free service for an
additional year for the emergency
service of SOS PS satellite that's
awesome that's super exciting and I
think it is one of those things that you
don't need on a day-to-day basis but
when you do like you're going to be so
happy that it's available definitely we
we we certainly hope that uh this will
give our users that additional peace of
mind so they have that additional
capability for safety um should they
ever need it so I guess one last thing
for anybody who is watching this what
are some safety tips that you can give
them to make sure that they have updated
on their phones to make sure that this
is ready to go if they ever do need it
yeah sure I definitely I we recommend
updating your medical ID uh as far of
the health app uh so that number one
even if you're not caught out of
coverage right and having that
information for First Responders to come
and be able to see if you have any
allergies or special medication needs um
from your lock screen without having to
unlock your phone um if you're not able
to do that and also that setting up that
emergency contact within metal CID
that's the person who would get these
notifications should you have crash
detection or emergency SOS via satellite
being used they would get those
notifications and be able to see that
transcript um with either the emergency
service provider or with the relay
centers that are helping you real time
in that emergency situation and the
other thing is we also encourage people
to try it out uh you may not always be
in a situation where you're off the grid
but what you can do is go into settings
emergency SOS and in there you can say
try the demo so you do have to be
outside because while it's not a real
emergency it is connecting to those real
satellites above you and it guides you
through the process to connect to the
satellite and so it's just something
good to be able to be familiar with with
yourself so that if you are in a real
emergency it's something that you
already um have some famili it with and
know how to do that's awesome I
definitely think everyone should test it
out because it is something that is in
that muscle memory so once you've done
it you can see the whole interface and
you'll be really comfortable if you ever
unfortunately have to use it for sure
for sure and and that's why we built
that demo in there so that you know when
you're not in a real emergency you still
have the ability to understand how it
works um it is very intuitive but if
you're the kind of person who likes to
be prepared and check things out it is
in there for you to try out that's
awesome well thank you so much and thank
you again for coming to chat with me and
also for extending an additional gear
for iPhone 14 users cuz I think it's
going to be an incredible feature and
I'm so glad that you guys have this now
available for everyone absolutely thank
you so much Justine yes thank you bye
thank you thank you guys so much for
watching I would love to hear from you
has anyone actually had to use any of
these satellite services I have seen a
bunch of Articles and interviews with
other people who have and thankfully it
has been something that has came to the
rescue and actually help them when in
need and with that I'll see you guys in
my next video if you want to watch some
more I will put some here on the end
screen bye